now to a story we've been following here
at eight news now las vegas real
water is now responding to claims about
the safety of its water
it's yesterday the company released this
statement saying quote
it takes the safety of our products and
concern for our customers health
seriously real water takes great strides
in every way to make sure our product is
safe for consumption
our goal the company says is to
diligently work with the fda to achieve
a swift resolution
real water says it was notified of a
problem with its alkaline product in
november again the company is based here
in las vegas
so now real water is asking all
retailers to pull its product
off shelves until the issues resolved
the fda and southern nevada health
district are working together to
investigate reports of what it calls
acute non-viral hepatitis
a number of illnesses linked to the
water have been found here in clark
county
including with several children in fact
one family is suing real water
after their child got sick